given that you're disrespecting the
power of the initial conditions uh let
me ask you about so how do you explain
that cellometer are able to produce such
incredible complexity given just basic
rules and basic initial conditions I
think that that you you this falls into
the Brower um Hilbert trap MH so how do
you get a cellular autometer produce
complexity you have a computer you
generate a display and you map the
change of that in time mhm there are
some Casa repeat like functions like
it's fascinating to me that for pi there
is a there is a Formula where you can go
to the the millionth decimal place of Pi
and read out the the the number without
having to go there but there are some
numbers where you can't do that you have
to just crank through MH there um
whether it's wol framan computational
irreducibility or some other thing it
doesn't matter but these
Casa that complexity is that just
complexity or a number that is basically
you're mining that number in time um you
know is that just a display screen for
that number that function well can't you
say the same thing about the complexity
on Earth then no because the complexity
on Earth um has a copy number and an
assembly index associated with that that
CA is just a number
running you don't think it has a copy
number wait wait a minute well it it
does in the human where where we're
looking at humans producing different
rules but then it's nested on selection
so those Cas are produced by selection
yeah I mean the ca is such a a
fascinating pseudo complexity generator
what I would love to do is understand um
quantify the degree of surprise in a CA
run it long enough MH but what that I
guess that means is we have to
instantiate we have to have a number of
experiments where we're generating
different rules and running them time SP
steps but oh got it ca is on mining
novelty mhm in the F from the you know
in the future by iteration right and
you're like oh that's great that's great
you didn't predict it some rules you can
predict that what's going to happen
other rules you can't so for me if
anything CA are evidence that the the
universe is too big to contain itself
because otherwise you'd know what the
rules are going to do forever
more right I guess you were saying that
the
physicist saying that all you need is
the initial conditions and the rules of
physics uh is somehow missing the bigger
picture and
yeah and you know if you look at CA all
you need is the initial condition and
the and the rules and then run the thing
you
need three things you need the initial
conditions you need the rules and you
need time iteration to mine it out
without the coordinate you can't get it
out sure and that's that that to use
fundamental and you can't predict it
from initial conditions if you could
then it' be fine and that time is res
the foundation of uh this is the history
the memory of each the things that
created it has to have that memory of
all the things that let up to it I think
it's a yeah you have to have the
resource yeah cuz time is a
fundamental resource and and um yeah I'm
becoming I think I had a
major
um uh Epiphany about Randomness but I
keep doing that every two days and then
it goes away again it's random you're
you're a Time Fundamentalist
you should be as well if you believe in
Free Will yeah the only conclusion is
there is time is fundamental otherwise
you cannot have free will it logically
follows
well my my the foundation of my belief
in Free Will is just
uh is is uh observation
driven but that's I think if you use
logic it's
like logically it seems like the
universe is deterministic look K
backwards in time and that's correct
universe
is